III The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
We'll back up and start again
since I just turned on my
microphone.
I started with the observation
that for most of recorded
history people thought
qualitatively, not
quantitatively.
They didn't know what
statistics were.
They must have had some
intuitive sense, for example,
that if you're old, you're
more likely to have bad
hearing than if you're young.
If you're old you're
more likely to die
than if you're young.
Things like that.
But they were just anecdotes,
and they had no careful way to
go from statements about
individuals to statements
about populations
or expectations.
This changed in about the middle
of the 17th century,
changed fairly dramatically,
when an Englishman named John
Graunt published something
called The Natural and
Political Observations Made Upon
the Bills of Mortality.
This was the first work in
recorded history that actually
used statistics.
And what he did is he looked
at the fairly comprehensive
statistics of when people died
in the city of London.
And from that, attempted to
produce a model that could be
used to predict the spread
of the plague.
And it turns out, he was
pretty good at it.
And that just changed the way
people started to think.
And since that time, people have
used statistics both to
inform and, unfortunately,
to mislead.
Some have willfully used
statistics to mislead, others
have merely been incompetent.
And that gets me to what I
want to talk about today,
which is statistics.
This is often attributed to Mark
Twain but, in fact, he
copied it from Benjamin
Disraeli, who said, "There are
three kinds of lies: lies,
damned lies, and statistics."
And there is, unfortunately,
a lot of truth in that.
More recently, in the '50s
Darrell Huff wrote a wonderful
book, I recommend it, called
How to Lie with Statistics.
Now here's a quote from the
book, "If you can't prove what
you want to prove, demonstrate
something else and pretend
that they're the same thing.
In the daze that follows the
collision of statistics with
the human mind, hardly anyone
will notice the difference."
Alas, that seems to be true.
So what I want to do today is
talk about a few ways in which
one can be fooled into drawing
inappropriate conclusions from
statistical data.
Now I trust that you
will use this
information only for good.
And it will make you a better
consumer and purveyor of data
rather than a better liar,
but that's up to you.
All right.
So let's start with the
first way out thing I
want to talk about.
And it's important to always
remember that no matter how
good your statistics are,
statistical measures don't
tell the whole story.
We've seen examples of this
already earlier in the term.
There are an enormous set of
statistics that can be
extracted from a data set.
And by carefully picking and
choosing among them, it's
possible to convey almost any
impression you want about the
same data set.
The best antidote, of course, is
to look at the data itself.
In 1973, the statistician John
Anscombe published a paper
with this set of data.
Four different examples where
he gave values for x and y,
nothing very sophisticated.
The interesting thing is that
in many ways, the statistics
for these four data sets
are very similar.
They have the same mean, the
same median, the same variance
for x and y both, the same
correlation between x and y.
And even if we use linear
regression to get a fit, we
get very similar things.
So let's look at it.
I actually wrote some
code to do that.
So this just reads in the data
set that we just had up, and
then plots some things
with it.
And so let's look at it.
So what you can see is, you have
these in your hand out,
we have four graphs,
four plots.
And I won't show you
them all because
they're all are identical.
What they all give me is a mean
of 7.5 and a whole bunch
of things, same to 17 decimal
places or so, the same median
and the same linear fit,
y equals 0.5x plus 3.
So I might write a paper in
which I would tell you that
well, from a statistical
sense, these data
sets are all the same.
Every statistical result I
ran said these things are
indistinguishable.
Well, is it true that
these data sets are
indistinguishable?
Well, one way to look at it is
to actually plot the points.
So we can run it with true,
which says in addition to
plotting the data, put points
on them in addition to
plotting the statistics.
And now we see something
fairly dramatic.
So for example, figure (2) and
figure (1) don't look a lot
like each other, when we
actually look at the data.
Figure (3) looks quite different
and figure (4) is
remarkably different.
Compare figure (4) to,
say, figure (1).
Again, these are all
in your hand out.
So the moral is pretty simple
here, and it's one we looked
at before, which is, don't
ever ignore the data.
Don't just look at statistics
about the data, try and find a
way to look at the
data itself.
Of course, it's easy enough to
look at the data, but how do
you look at it?
And the next thing to
remember is that
pictures can be deceiving.
There can be no doubt about the
utility of graphics for
quickly conveying information.
However, when used carelessly or
maliciously, a plot can be
highly misleading.
So let's look-- go back to the
PowerPoint, and look at this
plot of housing prices
in the Midwest.
So we've got a plot here, and
we've got years 2006, 2007 and
then in 2008 and 9,
we have quarters.
You may remember that there was
an event in the housing
market in 2008 precipitating the
global financial crisis.
And if we look at this, what
impression do we get about
housing prices in the mid
west during this period?
Well I would get the impression
that they are
remarkably stable.
You publish this and you say,
OK, look they really haven't
changed very much.
Maybe they've gone down
a little, but
nothing very serious.
If we compare that to this plot,
which is exactly the
same data, and now I ask
you about housing
prices in the Midwest.
Well, what you might
tell me is it's--
they're remarkably unstable.
And in fact, there was
clearly some sort of
horrible event here.
Exactly the same data, two
plots both of which are
truthful, but which give a
radically different impression
about what happened.
The chart on the right
was designed--
on the right in your handout--
was designed to show that they
were highly unstable.
So what's the difference?
What trick did I use to produce
these two plots?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In the more
stable one, you used
the logarithmic scale.
And then here only has
selected numbers so--
PROFESSOR: So that
was certainly one
trick that I performed.
That in the first chart,
I plotted the y-axis
logarithmically, which always
make things look like they are
changing less than if
I plot it linearly.
And in this chart, I
used a linear plot.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You see a much
narrower scale
on the second plot.
So that the magnitude of the
difference is much less
compared to the magnitude of the
whole graph of the scale.
PROFESSOR: So that's the other
thing I did is, if you look at
it, I sort of cheated.
I had full years here and
then I went to quarters.
So in part of my chart, the
resolution on the x is pretty
wide is a whole year, and then
part of it's on a quarter.
And, not surprisingly, since
we know that housing prices
change seasonally, they're
different in the spring than
in the winter, once I start
plotting quarters, even if
there had not been a crash, it
would have looked much less
stable in the out years,
because I changed the
resolution on the x-axis.
I didn't lie.
You can tell reading the
legend that I did that.
But I sure could have
fooled a lot of
people with these charts.
Here's another nice example
of statistics.
So this plots--
this is from a paper by two
professors, I think from Yale,
shows what you can do if you're
in the Ivy league, that
plots initials against GPA
for students at Yale.
And so you can see that if your
first name starts with
the letter A, I think it was
first initials, your GPA is
considerably higher than if it
starts with C or D. And if
your parents weren't nice enough
to give you an A name,
you could hope they at least
gave you a B name.
And you certainly don't
want them to give
you a C or a D name.
So if you're Charlene or David
you could have a real problem.
I have to say my first child
was named David.
His GPA might have been
somewhere in there.
All right --
clearly it matters.
Well, what tricks did
I perform here?
AUDIENCE: There is very
little disparity in x.
You are going from 3.32 to--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what I did here is I made the
range on the y-axis very
small, ranging from 3.32 to
3.38, not a big difference.
However, because that's the
whole thing, it looks like
it's a big difference.
You will often see this when
you, say, look at things in
newspapers where, in fact,
someone has manipulated one of
the axes to make things
look big or small.
If I had ranged this from a GPA
of 0.0 to a GPA of 4.0,
the highest GPA at Yale,
this difference would
have looked very tiny.
But I didn't --
actually it wasn't I. I actually
copied this from
their paper.
This was the way they presented
it in their paper.
Because they were trying to
argue in the paper that your
name had a big influence
on your life.
And they used many statistics
including your grades.
And so they actually formatted
it kind of like this to try
and give you this impression.
Now later we'll see another
statistical sin they committed
in this paper, which, basically,
was designed to
show that in your name
was destiny.
And they had many
other things.
If you're a baseball player, and
your name starts with K,
you're more likely
to strike out.
Because K is the symbol for
strikeouts in a baseball score
book, a lot of implausible
things.
All right.
Moving right along, probably
the most serious and common
statistical error is
the one known as
Garbage In Garbage Out.
And it's so common that people
typically refer to it by its
acronym GIGO --
Garbage In Garbage Out.
A classic example of this
occurred and, we could look at
more recent examples,
but I don't want to
offend any of you.
In 1840, United states census
showed that insanity among
free blacks and mulattoes was
roughly 10 times more common
than insanity among enslaved
blacks or mulattoes.
And the conclusion from this
was obvious, I guess.
US Senator, former Vice
President, and later,
Secretary of State John C.
Calhoun concluded from the
census and I quote, "The data
on sanity revealed In this
census is unimpeachable.
From it, our nation must
conclude that the abolition of
slavery would be to the African,
a curse." Because
after all, if you freed them
from slavery, they
would all go insane.
That's what the statistics
reported, he said.
Now never mind it was soon clear
that in fact that census
was riddled with errors.
And John Quincy Adams, a former
Vice President and
Massachusetts resident responded
to Calhoun and said,
no that's a ridiculous
conclusion.
The census is full of errors.
Calhoun, being a very patient
person, explained to Adams the
following, "There were so many
errors, that they balanced one
another out, and led to the same
conclusion just as much
as if they were all correct."
There were just enough errors
that you could be OK.
Well, what was he relying on?
What should he have said if he
wanted to make this statement
more mathematically precise?
What he was basically implying
is that the measurement errors
are unbiased and independent of
each other and, therefore,
almost identically distributed
on either side of the mean.
I see a typo, I might
as well fix it.
Might as well make it big
enough to fix it.
That's interesting.
If he had made this much more
precise statement, then you
could have had an meaningful
discussion--
assuming it was possible to have
a meaningful discussion
with John Calhoun, which
is perhaps dubious--
about whether or not, in fact,
the errors are independent.
Because if they're not, if, for
example, they represent
bias in the people compiling the
data, then you cannot rely
upon statistical methods
to say that they'll
balance each other out.
You remember way back in Gauss'
time, Gauss talked
about this when he talked about
the normal distribution.
And said, well, if we take
these astronomical
measurements and we assume our
errors are independent and
normally distributed, then we
can look at the mean and
assume that that's close
to the truth.
Well, those are important
assumptions which in this case
turned out to be not correct.
And, in fact, it was later shown
that the errors did not
balance each other out nicely.
And in fact, today you can say
that no statistical conclusion
can be drawn from that.
On the other hand recently,
the US National Research
Council, perhaps the most
prestigious academic
organization in the United
states, published a ranking of
all universities
in the country.
And it was later shown that it
was full of garbagy input.
And they did extensive
statistical analysis and
published it on data that turned
out to be just wrong.
And it was very embarrassing.
Now the good news is
MIT came out near
the top of this analysis.
And the bad news is we can't
conclude that it actually
should have been near the top
because who knows about the
quality of the data, but
kind of embarrassing.
All right.
Moving right along, another very
common way to lie with
statistics is to exploit what's
called the cum hoc ergo
propter hoc fallacy.
So anyone here study Latin?
Bunch of techy--
Oh OK.
Well what does it mean?
AUDIENCE: With this therefore,
because of this?
PROFESSOR: Boy, your
Latin is good.
Either that or you just
know statistics.
But I have to say that was the
most fluent translation I've
had it all the years I've
asked this question.
I hit the relay man-- the relay
woman on the throw.
All right.
Yes, with this, therefore
because of this.
I don't know why but
statisticians, like physicians
and attorneys, like
to show off by
phrasing things in Latin.
So for example, it is a
statistical fact that college
students, including MIT
students, who regularly attend
lectures have higher GPAs than
students who attend lectures
only sporadically.
So that would tell us that those
of you in the room are
likely to have a higher GPA than
the various students in
6.00 who are not in this room.
I hope it's true.
Now if you're a professor who
gives these lectures, what you
want to believe it's because the
lectures are so incredibly
informative, that we make the
students who come much smarter
and, therefore, they
do better.
And so we'd like to
assume causality.
Because I give beautiful
lectures and you choose to
come, you will get a better
grade in 6.00.
Well, yes, there's
a correlation.
It's unquestionably true, but
causation is hard to jump to.
For example, maybe it's the
point that students who bother
to come to lecture also bother
to do the problem sets, and
are just more conscientious.
And whether they came to lecture
or not, the fact that
they're more conscientious would
give them better GPAs.
There's no way I know to
separate those two things,
other than doing a controlled
experiment, right?
Maybe kicking half of you out of
lecture every day and just
see how it goes.
But it's dangerous but again,
you can read things like the
faculty newsletter, which will
talk about how important it is
to come the lecture because
you'll do better.
Because whoever wrote that
article for the faculty
newsletter didn't understand
this--
this fallacy, or was just
thinking wishfully.
Another nice example, one that
was in the news not too long
ago, has to do with the flu.
This was the cases of
flu in New York
State in recent years.
And you'll notice that there was
a peak in 2009, and that
was the famous swine flu
epidemic, which I'm sure you
all remember.
Now, if you look at this
carefully, or even not too
carefully, you'll notice a
correlation between when
schools are in session and
when the flu occurs.
That in fact, during those
months when schools are in
session, there are more cases of
flu than in the months when
school is not in session, high
schools, colleges, whatever.
Quite a strong correlation,
in fact.
This led many to conclude that
going to school is an
important causative factor
in getting the flu.
And so maybe you shouldn't
have come to the lectures
because you would have just
gotten the flu by doing so.
And in fact because of this,
you had many parents not
sending their kids to school
during the swine flu epidemic.
And in fact, you had many
schools closing in some
communities because of the
swine flu epidemic.
Well, let's think about it.
Just as you could use this
correlation to conclude that
going to school causes the swine
flu, you could have also
used it to prove that the flu
causes you to go to school.
Because more people are in
school when the flu season is
at it's height.
And therefore, it's the growth
of flu that causes people to
go to school.
That's an equally valid
statistical
assumption from this data.
Kind of a weird thing but
it's true, right?
Just as we could conclude that
having a high GPA causes
people to come to the lecture.
You look at your GPA every
morning, and if it's high
enough, you come to lecture,
otherwise, you don't.
You could draw that conclusion
from the data as well.
The issue here that you have to
think about is whether or
not there is what's called a
lurking variable, some other
variable that's related to the
other two, and maybe that's
the causative one.
So for example, a lurking
variable here is that the
school season coincides with
or the non-school season,
maybe I should say, coincides
with the summer.
And in fact, if you study the
flu virus in a lab, you will
discover that it survives longer
in cold weather than in
hot and humid weather.
When it's cold and dry, the flu
virus will survive for a
longer time on a surface
than it will when
it's warm and humid.
And so in fact, maybe it's the
weather, not the presence of
schools, that causes the flu
to be more virulent during
certain times of the year.
In fact, it's probably
likely true.
So there is a lurking variable
that we have to consider, and
maybe that's the causative
factor.
Now, this can actually lead
to some really bad
decisions in the world.
I'm particularly interested in
issues related to health care
and public health.
In 2002, roughly 6 million
American women were taking
hormone replacement therapy, in
the belief that this would
substantially lower their risk
of cardiovascular disease.
It was argued that women over a
certain age or of a certain
age, if you took extra hormones,
they were less
likely to have a heart attack.
This belief was supported by
several published studies in
highly reputable journals in
which they showed a strong
correlation between being on
hormone replacement therapy
and not having cardiovascular
disease.
And this data had been around
a while and, as I said, by
2002 in the US, roughly
6 million women
were on this therapy.
Later that year, the Journal
of the American Medical
Society published an article
asserting that in fact being
on this therapy increased
women's risk of
cardiovascular disease.
It made you more likely to
have a heart attack.
Well, how could this
have happened?
After the new study came out,
people went back and
reanalyzed the old study and
discovered that the women in
that study who'd been on hormone
replacement therapy
were more likely than the other
women in the group to
have also better diet and be on
a better exercise regimen.
In fact, they were women who
were more health conscious.
So there were the lurking
variables of diet and exercise
and other things that were, in
fact, probably the causative
factors in better health, not
the replacement therapy.
But there was this lurking
variable that had not been
discovered in the initial
analysis of the data.
So what we saw is that taking
hormone replacement therapy
and improved cardiac health were
coincident effects of a
common cause, that is to say
being health conscious.
Kind of a strange thing but
a true and sad story.
All right.
Moving right along, another
thing to be cautious of is
non-response bias and
related problem of a
non-representative sample.
You'll probably recall that when
I first started talking
about statistics and the use of
randomness, I said that all
statistical techniques are based
upon the assumption that
by sampling a subset of a
population, we can infer
things about the population
as a whole.
And that's true, typically,
because if random sampling is
used, you can make assumptions
that the distribution of
results from the random sample,
if it's large enough,
will be the same as a
distribution of results from
the whole population.
And that's why we typically
want to sample randomly.
And so for all the simulations
we looked at, we used random
sampling to try and ensure that
a small number of samples
would give us something
representative of the
population.
And then we use statistical
techniques to answer the
question about how many random
samples we needed.
But those techniques were only
valid if the samples were
indeed random.
Otherwise, you can analyze it
to your heart's content and
any conclusions you've drawn are
likely to be fallacious.
Unfortunately, many studies,
particularly in the social
sciences, are based on
what is often called
a convenience sampling.
So for example, if you look
at psychological--
psychology journals, you'll find
that many psychological
studies use populations of
undergraduates for their studies.
Why did they do this?
Is it because they believe
that undergraduates are
representative of the population
as a whole?
No.
It's because they're captive.
They have to agree to
participate, right?
It's a convenience if you happen
to be at a university
to do your experiments
on undergraduates.
And so they do that and then
they say, well, the
undergraduates are just like
the population as a whole.
You may have observed that at
least at this institution, the
undergraduates are probably
not representative of the
population as a whole.
A well-known example of what you
can do with this occurred
during World War II.
Whenever an allied plane would
return from a bombing run over
Germany, the plane would be
inspected to see where flak
had hit it.
So the planes would fly over
to drop bombs, the Germans
would shoot flak at the planes
to try and knock
them out the air.
They'd come back to England,
they'd get inspected, they'd
say, well the flak hit this part
of the plane more often
than that part of the
plane on average.
And so they would reinforce the
skin of those parts of the
plane where they expected the
flak to hit, to try and make
the plane less likely to be
damaged in future runs, or the
planes in general.
What's wrong with this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They're not getting
the planes that dropped?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
What they're not sampling is the
planes that never made it
back from the bombing, ooh, that
never made it back from
the bombing runs because they
weren't there to sample.
And in fact maybe it's the case
that what they were doing
was reinforcing those parts of
the planes where it didn't
matter if you got hit by flak
because it wouldn't cause a
plane to crash, and not
reinforcing those parts of the
planes that were most
vulnerable to
being damaged by flak.
They did a convenient
sampling, they drew
conclusions, and they probably
did exactly the wrong thing in
what they chose to reinforce
in the airplanes.
This particular error is called
non-response bias where
you do some sort of survey, for
example, and some people
don't respond and, therefore,
you ignore what
they would have said.
It's perhaps something we see
when we do the underground
guide to Course 6.
In fact I should point out
that it's now online.
And it would be good if each of
you would go and rate this
course, rate the lectures,
rate the TAs, et cetera.
We actually do read them and it
makes a difference in how
we teach the course in
subsequent terms.
But there's clearly a bias.
You know, maybe only the
people who really feel
strongly about the course,
either positively or
negatively, bother to
fill out the survey.
And we draw the conclusions
that there's a bimodal
distribution, and nobody thinks
it's kind of mediocre,
because they don't bother
responding.
Or maybe only the people who
hate the course respond, and
we think everybody
hates the course.
Who knows.
It's a big problem.
We see it, it's a big problem
today with telephone polls,
where you get more convenient
sampling and
non-representative samples,
where a lot of polls are done
using telephones.
By law, these pollsters cannot
call cell phones, so they only
call land lines.
How many of you have
a land line?
Let the record show, nobody.
How many of your parents
have a land line?
Let the record show, pretty
much everybody.
Well, that means your parents
are more likely to get sampled
than you when there's a poll
of, say, who should be
nominated for president.
And so any of these polls
that are based on
telephones will be biased.
And, unfortunately, their poll
may just say, a telephone
sample, and people may
not realize the
implication of that.
That whole part of the
population is under sampled.
There are lots of examples
of this.
All right.
Moving along, another problem
we often see is data
enhancement.
It's easy to read much more
into data than it actually
implies, especially when
viewed out of context.
So on April 29, 2009, CNN
reported that quote, "Mexican
health officials suspect that
the swine flu outbreak has
caused more than 159 deaths and
roughly 2,500 illnesses."
It was pretty scary stuff at the
time, and people got all
worried about the swine flu.
On the other hand, how many
deaths a year do you think are
attributable to the
conventional
seasonal flu in the US?
Anyone want to hazard a guess?
36,000.
So 36,000 people a year, on
average, will die from the
seasonal flu, which sort of puts
in prospective that 159
deaths from the swine flu
maybe shouldn't be so
terrifying.
But again, people typically did
not report both of those.
Another great statistic, and
accurate, is that most auto
accidents happen within
10 miles of home.
I'm sure many of you
have heard that.
So what does that mean?
Almost nothing.
Most driving is done
with 10 miles--
within 10 miles of home.
And besides that, what does
home mean in this context?
What home means is
the registration
address of the car.
So if I were to choose to
register my car in Alaska,
does that mean I'm less likely
to have an accident driving
around MIT?
I don't think so.
Again, it's a kind
of a meaningless.
Another aspect of this
is people often
extrapolate from data.
So we can look at an example
of internet usage.
This is kind of a fun one too.
So what I've plotted here is
the internet usage in the
United states as a percentage
of population.
And I plotted of this from--
starting at 1994.
And the green line, or actually,
the blue line there
are the points and the green
line is a linear fit.
If you looked at my code, you'd
see I was using polyfit
with a 1 to get a line to fit,
and you can see it's a pretty
darn good fit.
So people actually looked at
these things and used this to
extrapolate internet usage
going forward.
So we can do that.
Now, we'll run the same
code with the
extrapolation turned on.
And so figure (1) is the same
figure (1) as before, same
data, same fit.
And here's figure (2).
And you'll notice that as of
last year about 115% of the US
population was using the
internet, probably not true.
It may be possible in sports
to give 110%, but in
statistics it's not.
Again, you see this all the
time when people are doing
these projections.
They'll say, fit some data,
they extrapolate into the
future without understanding
why maybe that isn't a good
thing to do.
We saw that by when we were
modeling springs, right?
We could accurately project
linearly until we exceeded the
constant of elasticity at which
point our linear model
was totally broken.
So you always need to have some
reason other than just
fitting the data to believe that
what you're doing makes
actual sense.
All right.
The final one I want to talk
about is what is typically
called in the literature the
Texas sharpshooter fallacy.
And this is a little bit tricky
to understand sometimes.
Actually, is there anyone
here from Texas?
Oh good, so no one will
be offended by this.
Well imagine that you're driving
down some country road
in Texas and that
you see a barn.
And that barn has six targets
painted on it, and in the dead
center of each target, you
find a bullet hole.
So you're driving, your pretty
impressed, and you stop.
And you see the owner of the
barn and you say, you must be
a damn good shot.
And he says, absolutely,
I never miss.
At which point the farmer's
wife walks out and says,
that's right there ain't a man
in the state of Texas who is
more accurate with
a paint gun.
What did he do?
He shot six bullets into
the barn, and he
was a terrible shot.
They were all over the place.
Then he went and painted a
target around each of them.
And it looked like he
was a great shot.
Now you might think that, well
that's silly, no one would do
that in practice.
But in fact, it happens all
of the time in practice.
A classic of this genre appeared
in the magazine New
Scientist, in 2001.
And it reported that a research
team led by John
Eagles of the Royal Cornhill
Hospital in Aberdeen, had
discovered that and I quote,
"Anorexic women are most
likely to have been born in
the spring or early summer
between March and June.
In fact, there were
more than--
there were more than 13%--
there were 13% more anorexics
born on average in those
months, and 30% more anorexics,
on average, in
June."
Now, let's look at this
worrisome statistic.
Are any of you women
here born in June?
All right.
Well, I won't ask about
your health history.
But maybe you should be
worried, or maybe not.
So let's look at how they
did this study.
You may wonder why so many of
these studies are all studies
about women's health.
And then, perhaps, because
they're all
done by male doctors.
Anyway, the team studied 446
women who had been diagnosed
as anorexic.
So if you divide that by 12
what you've discovered is
that, on average, there should
have been 37 women born in
each of those months,
of the 446.
And in fact, in June, there were
48 anorexic women born.
So they said, well, how likely
is this to have occurred
simply by chance?
Well as I am want to do in
such occasions, I checked
their analysis, and I
wrote a little piece
of code to do that.
So trying to figure out what's
the probability of 48 women
being born in June, I ran
a simulation in which I
simulated 446 births and chose
a month at random, and looked
at the probability.
And let's see what it
was when we run it.
Oops, well we didn't
want these graphs.
The probability of at least 48
births in June was 0.042.
So in fact, pretty low.
You might say, well, what's
the odds of this
happening by accident?
Pretty small.
Therefore, maybe we are really
on to something.
Maybe it has to do with the
conditions of the birth and
the weather or who knows what.
Well, what's wrong with
this analysis?
Well, one way to look at it is
this analysis would have been
perfectly valid if the
researchers had started with a
hypothesis that there are more
babies born in June than in
any other month-- more future
anorexics born in June than in
any other month, and then run
this experiment to test it,
and validated it.
So if they had started with the
hypothesis, and then from
the hypothesis conducted what's
called a prospective
study then they would have,
perhaps, valid reason to
believe that the study supports
the hypothesis.
But that's not what they did.
Instead what they did is they
looked at the data and then
chose a hypothesis that matched
the data, the Texas
sharpshooter fallacy.
Given that that was the
experiment they performed, the
right question to ask is not
what is the probability that
you had 48 future anorexics born
in June, but what was the
probability that you have 48
future anorexics born in at
least one of the 12 months?
Because that's what they were
really doing, right?
So therefore, we should really
have run this simulation.
Similar to the previous one,
again, these are in your hand
out, but is there at least
one month in which
there were 48 births?
And if we run that we'll see
that the probability is over
40%, not so impressive as 4%.
So in fact, we see that we
probably shouldn't draw any
conclusion.
The probability of this
happening by pure accident is
almost 50%.
So why should we believe that
it's somehow meaningful.
Again, an example of the Texas
sharpshooter fallacy that
appeared in the literature and
a lot of people fell for it.
And if we had more time, I
would give you many more
examples, but we don't.
I'll see you on Thursday,
on Tuesday, rather.
Two more lectures to go.
On Tuesday, I'm going to go over
some code that I'll be
asking you to look
at in preparation
for the final exam.
And then on Thursday, we'll
wrap things up.